i'm gonna okay so here's how i'm gonna
preface this
you have total veto power over any of my
proposals
and i know you know that but i really
mean that if
i'm showing you something with openings
it's like
close you know it's like a pair of jeans
that you're gonna wear for the next set
seven years
okay it's totally not like that but you
get what i'm saying
[Music]
i consulted with some friends i put some
thought into this and here are my
proposals
invited you right here now
let's first take uh black so your move
of course has always been e5 right
that's like the right of passage
my proposal is for me to teach you the
sicilian defense
wow now let me explain the rationale
behind this i'm going to come at it from
three angles
first of all uh in this attack are you
aware of what white's main response to
the sicilian is this is not what you're
going to face most commonly
but have you heard of the open sicilian
uh only from you i think so the open
cecilian this is white's main line
response to most sicilians is knight f3
followed by d4
opening up the center and against the
open sicilian there is a
incredibly tricky opening called the
accelerated dragon
it is an opening where you feel
encountered the bishop very very early
and it comes from the non-accelerated
dragon the regular dragon
is d6 knight f6 and now g6
and chess players as you know are known
for their incredible originality
apparently this resembles
a dragon you can kind of see that the
curves of a dragon
and it also is a very aggressive opening
so it's like a fire breathing
dragon kind of opening i'm sure there
was some
namer that got off on this but the
regular dragon
has kind of fallen out of favor it's
incredibly theoretical you're gonna have
to do hours and hours of memorization
and uh white gets most of the fun here
but with the accelerated dragon you
actually develop the knight first
and the accelerated dragon is a lot less
scary to play
than the regular dragon and it's a lot
more tricky
so you might not face the open sicilian
because most people of your rating
don't really know how to play against
the sicilian and that
segues me into the second appeal of the
situation most people you play
are going to mess this up pretty badly a
lot of people are going to play this
like an italian they're going to play
bishop c4 here
right they're going to go well this is
the same as italian
but the thing is after bishop c4 um
black is already slightly better and i
will show you exactly how to play this
position
you're going to get the kind of position
you can immediately play for a win in
it's going to be unbalanced
and this is going to allow you
ultimately to work on some of the
concepts and put them into practice
so that's i would say reason number two
most people you play
are going to immediately screw up and
reason number three as i've been hinting
at is that i want you to expand
basically your horizons by which i mean
i want you to
expand your ability to play various
kinds of positions get more on balance
positions and would it make sense if i
said that
after e5 the positions tend to remain
relatively balanced in most of your
games for some time
i'm gonna plunge you into the mariana
trench into the freaking
deepest of defense but first we're going
to do
some very thorough preparation you're
going to know exactly what you're doing
and i can guarantee you
if you do a little bit of review we
cover all the bases you're going to
start getting advantages with black in
the positions that you like
so that's my proposal i know you don't
know much about this attilionet so it's
hard for you to make an informed
uh decision but how does this sound in
general
oh anything with accelerated dragon in
the names got me
fully on board excellent it worked
that's not actually what it's no
it actually is what it's called yes it
actually is what it's called it's called
accelerating you cannot be mistaken for
anything else
and the accelerated dragon to whom i'm
just looking up to whom do we owe
the uh deepest debt of gratitude who was
the first person
to play the accelerated dragon in
recorded history let's see
i'm running a little search it was 1851
a guy named
marmaduke wyville wow i don't think
anybody's had that first name in about a
hundred years
yeah wow that's [ __ ] awesome that's
like one of those british names like
eggbert
and marmaduke weibo actually won the
game
against alexander kennedy in 1851 london
he was the first person to play the
accelerated dragon
it was played only a handful of times in
the 1800s and it really only caught on
in the
in the last 50 years so
it's new and it's incredibly tricky and
some of the tricks within the main lines
are really really cool okay so
without further ado that's from the
black side we will start with this now
very quickly
from the white side of course i think
you should keep e4
now we have several important things we
need to do first of all i know that some
people in the fog champs will definitely
not everybody will play e5
so you need a line against the sicilian
and we need to look at some of the
sidelines the french
this is all familiar to you right you
faced this before the karo khan
stuff like that and it won't take us
long we'll just have one session where
we look at all these sidelines
and against the sicilian i'll show you a
line that i actually played as
as a kid which is the c3 sicilian super
dangerous line
so you'll have you'll be booked up on
both ends of the sicilian
now against e5 i put again a lot of
thought into this i fluctuated
vacillated i couldn't decide but i think
i've decided on an opening
that you're going to really enjoy and
with which you're going to kick a lot of
ass
and that is called the vienna gambit
so basically the move is knight c3
this is already not what you play right
right
and this is considered by by many to be
senseless because why play knight c3
when you
can play knight f3 but there is a very
specific follow-up
after knight f6 you play the move f4
now what is what is 2f4 called
what do you mean that's a gambit kings
gambit right that's the king's gambit
this is basically a very much improved
version of the king's cabin
and in many games your opponent is gonna
greedily take the pawn black is already
in huge trouble here
by move four can you maybe tell me why
black is in trouble think about
which think about what the knight on f6
allows white to do
white basically makes a huge claim in
the center immediately with tempo
is it just pushing up the pawn again
attacking the knight bingo
now where can this freaking knight go
nowhere right has to go back to g8
and we're gonna talk about the theory
here i analyzed
the hell out of this uh for a student a
couple of months ago
so you're gonna benefit from some cool
analysis black is already in big trouble
here some of the lines that we're gonna
look at are super cool you sacrifice
more pawns
but it's not the sort of thing where you
have to always sacrifice a million
pieces
at most you sacrifice two puns and again
this will allow you to get the kinds
positions i think you want to get
attacking positions open positions
and uh most importantly it's going to
help you
put into practice and i would say
crystallize the concept we talk about so
that's my recommendation
also sounds reasonable very much so okay
well i've set the table i got it now i
gotta deliver now the less glamorous
part
uh i think just today we'll do a little
bit of sicilian i'll introduce you to it
and uh we'll go from there okay
so e4 c5 um a good way to approach
openings in general i like to get the
lay of the land first what is it that
we're going to have to look at
so that you know we can basically know
approximately where we are
now knight f3 is by far the main mode
the alternatives to knight f3 there is
c3
what is the idea of this move you should
be able to immediately
it's getting ready to prep d4 right
i'm getting ready to write d4 so black
has to respond to that
uh there is the move d4 immediately some
people who don't really know what
they're doing do this
and now there's the smithmore gambit
which is c3 not a lot of people at your
level play it
some people will play queen takes d4 you
can immediate you can already tell me
what black does here
uh he just develops the knight normally
with tempo cc exactly and let's say the
queen drops back
you already have the necessary
information to play the next move
play it like an accelerated dragon yeah
so now i'm just going to bring
the uh c c
pawn to c4 right um
wait it's it but it's black to move oh
oh wait what
i mean you're playing black i i thought
i was playing white
i'm sorry no no no it's all good but
we're looking at like the sicilian from
black's perspective
gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha you were
just testing me
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
now i'm just developing on the other
side right so i'm going
knight to f6 was that that's fine but if
you play it in the spirit of the
accelerated dragon
then you would play g6 first mission i
always be in cat of the bishop
most of the time except for one line
which we're going to talk about right
now so that's d4 we'll
we'll deepen our knowledge of all of
this as well i'm trying to just give you
the lay of the land for now and then
finally there's knight f3
by a country mile you're going to face
this move most often so now you play
knight c6 right
yeah and the move that according to my
training with my students around your
level is bishop c4 because again people
play the italian against e5 and they
don't sense the difference
the key difference here is that the e7
pawn has not moved to e5 yet
so what move becomes possible now
and this basically takes the entire
point out of the move bishop c4
which is of course the pressure of the
pawn
i can just move it up to e6 instead
right you can just move it up to e6
blunting the bishop and preparing
potentially what move
uh d5 right potentially you don't
necessarily want to rush with that move
the move is e6
and normally white plays one of several
moves you can either castle he can go
knight c3
let's begin by assuming that white
castles now once again you have several
moves the move that i like is knight f6
okay now you are essentially inviting
the move e5 which would already be
pretty bad
where do you think the knight should go
and in the sicilian it's going to be
very important that you remain
aggressive
that mentality has to be basically
permanent
did we just get it to e4 right away well
the knight on e4 take a good hard look
at this knight is it supported by
anything
and look at this pawn on e5 it's
stopping at stu retreat square so d3
would trap the knight
so you're right in terms of the knight
advancing but this pawn on e5 is what
you need to exploit here
okay so uh i mean i can't just take it
with the knight because i don't know not
yet
but you can move this knight to attack
it yeah so i just bring it up to g4
you bring it up to g4 and after rookie
one
you can now undermine this pawn
basically which gives you really nice
development with what move
get rid of the spawn force forcibly
when i say that you should be thinking
of pawn moves because a pawn mode
essentially offers a pawn trade
and gets that pawn off the board yeah i
just don't know which one do i do with
the f
pawn or the d pawn what does your gut
say which move seems less weakening
d-pawn yeah and also but what the d-pawn
does is it allows you now to develop
your bishop to d6
okay let's say white goes h3 you drop
the knight back in
black is very nice development where is
that bishop on c8
going to develop itself too this is a
very sexy development square
uh eventually or right now uh basically
on the next move like
where well let's say eventually where is
the ideal square for that bishop
wouldn't i want it on the long diagonal
absolutely
b6 bishop b7 and this is called the
horowitz bishops there's actually a name
for bishops configured in this way
they're both aimed at the king side
black's got amazing development
does that make sense quick tactical
question of d4
in your head let's say c takes d4 knight
takes d4 knight takes d4 queen takes d4
black to mode and win
i i win the queen you do with one move
and you had a similar idea against iraq
that one time in fog champs one
what you need to notice here is the
standoff between the queens
yeah so the only thing separating the
queens is the bishop in front of it uh
so let's get it the hell out
so i just move it do i move but but
where though oh i deliberately checked
i think i don't care exactly and then
you win the queen
that is super important occurs often in
the city i guarantee you i'm saying it
right here right now
you're going to win i would even go so
far as to say a pog jams game with a
concept like this
you're gonna win a queen like this
because people fall into this all the
time
okay so in this position
white doesn't have to go e5 if white
goes d3
expand in the center
and this is a move we kind of referenced
just
a second ago are we just going right
there at d4 with the knight
um okay so we're going d5 i got excited
there when you said that the word d
um okay gotcha now knight d4
but but i'm not gonna let you go that
easily right you say a move like this
uh in front of me and you're going to
hear it from me so knight t4
let me shall i list the flaws of this
move
i want to hear every single god damn i'm
gonna i'm gonna twist the knife and so
far you're never to get it out now the
first thing is it doesn't develop a
piece and it doesn't occupy the standard
with pawns
the fact that a piece stands in the
center like this
doesn't really mean anything so for
example white can simply play c3
and the knight is just going to have to
move but the other thing is i can take
this knife
and the nice knight is replaced by is
this pawn good
now you've got double puns right yeah
now you've got doubled pawns so
and third of all white can just ignore
with knight c3
so when you are centralizing a piece
when you're putting a piece in the
center
generally speaking the purpose of that
is if that piece is on an outpost or if
that piece is attacking something
specific
right and that's the mentality you want
to start having like every time you put
a piece on a square
what exactly is that piece doing there
if you ask that question of the d4
knight
you can't come up with anything it's not
threatening anything it's not doing
anything
right right sorry to harp on this
so much but that was an instructive
mistake i joke that was an instruction
mistake so the move is d5
you're attacking this twice why must
take you take with the e pawn
what opens up now we now have the e-file
open
white has default but what is black
house uh we're attacking the bishop and
we also have
does bishop think about it where can it
now go
are we pinning the knight potentially
but first we must finish our king side
development we go bishop e7
the reason we go to e7 is in order to
take the sting out of the move rookie
one
then we castle black is better we have
bigger control of the center this bishop
will come out either to g4 or f5
it should just make sense to you that
black's position is really comfortable
does that kind of make sense at some
point when we finish the theoretical
part we will practice
all of these positions and we will
deepen your understanding but right now
i'm giving you the lay of the land this
is the most common line you're going to
face
that's why we're spending the longest on
it and lastly
if white goes rook to e1 and defends the
pawn
would d5 be a good idea here
the only thing i see is it oh it gives
the check right away so i won't be able
to block with the bishop
well so what does white do after d5 uh
he just
takes right and can you take with the
pawn no because it's bend it's fencing
i have to take with the knight not break
so you actually have a tactic here
and this tactic isn't i'll just show you
because this is hard mode to find i take
c4
you've seen this idea before what is the
follow-up
am i just attacking with pawns here with
that fork at d5
yep and white is forced to give up the
bishop
so you've traded pieces but white has
given up his light squared bishop that's
a super important piece
the reason that is a super important
piece let's say knight c3 you can just
drop your queen back
again you're going to do the same thing
you did earlier you're going to put your
bishops on d6 and b7
you're going to have the two bishop
advantage in a great position this rook
on e4 is also kind of sticking out like
a sore
thumb does that make sense
okay so we looked at all three of the
possibilities here
okay so that's what happens in bishop c4
basically you go knight f6 you go e6 and
f6
and then you either go d5 or you can
consider this idea of knight takes c4
when do i want to take on e4 over doing
just d5
so taking on e4 is rare you basically
only want to take in this in the event
of this
or if white defends with the queen you
all you actually could consider taking
on e4 here
because you have the same thing and it
is true that white can force a queen
trade
but again you have the two bishops you
have better control of the center that's
another thing i want you to start doing
you need to be comfortable
sometimes going for the end game if
you're better
and thank you chest dojo for the raid so
does that make sense yeah that makes
sense so you would go knight take c4
in the event that white doesn't play d3
um if white does play d3 you go d5
the trade is forced and you move your
bishop out you castle development is
very natural remember the same
principles
that apply in e5 openings apply here
it's not a different language
it's similar position similar concepts
it's just something fresh
something more open no we didn't
fianchetto in this position here
no so this is the only line this line
and then the c3 sitalian too where you
do not fiam carry your bishop
so we only do this when they push the
bishop out to c4 this is yes
and the reason how do you remember this
because the move bishop c4 you got think
about it like oh he's trying to play the
italian against the sicilian
well why is this not the same thing
because the pawn hasn't moved yet which
means the pawn can now blunt the bishop
okay so perhaps just
the only other thing i think we can we
can look at today i don't want to
overwhelm you and i know this is kind of
relatively dull it's just sort of a must
you do this once and then you
have a blast let's take a quick look at
just a couple moves here in the main
line is that fine with you
why boy and okay so you go
g6 your next move is bishop g7 now
golden rule number one it is extremely
important
that you never play e6 in these
positions never combine
the moves g6 and e6
in the accelerated track and um
okay never also never say never but uh
that is about as hard and fast of a rule
as there is
now you might ask well why the hell am i
so worried about playing e6 right
so and why would you play six so a lot
of people play e6
because it defends this square and they
think oh maybe i'll put the bishop here
you bishop always fianchettos
let me show you a game that i played or
rather a game segment
i played many years ago and this will
show you all you need to know okay
this is worth it and you get to see me
suffer even though i won this game in
the end you get to see like
nine-year-old daniel
get absolutely destroyed so
in the opening uh i am playing black
here this was 2005 so i was nine i was
rated 1800
he played the smith war again but i
referenced this where you basically
sacrifice upon we will talk about this
but you will not accept the gambit in
order to get rapid development here's
guess what i did i played knight c6
um bishop c4 and i played g6
okay bishop c4 bishop g7
castles sorry you played knight f3
bishop g7 castles and guess what move i
played here
oh my god you didn't need to i freaking
did this and then i got
several limbs of mine chopped off by my
coach
um i think i still remember that lesson
after this game
uh the kinds of things i heard you will
not believe
because to a russian player this move is
is anathema it's unthinkable
now why is this move so freaking bad
because it weakens
this square and the darks look at the
dark squares
d6 and c7 you see how weak they are yeah
how can white stick the ultimate piece
onto d6
they're just going with the queen not
with the queen there's an even better
piece he did put the queen on d6 in us
in a move but how about the knight
get the knight there he just brings the
knight to e area to um
dude yes okay
well potentially knight d6 you can see
how devastating that is right that
literally entombs black's entire queen
set i play knight f6
but instead of knight d6 which would be
good now he plays queen d6 which is even
better
what is he threatening
um what is his next move going to be
he's going to pre-move this
literally
don't overthink it
so let's say a6
i don't uh simpler than you think it is
it wins the game immediately and i think
again you need to
be careful about assuming a square is
defended a square can be attacked more
than once even if it's defended by a
piece
it's still accessible
what two squares did i mention when i
when i said e6
this was one of them e7 and c7
yeah knight c7 wins the queen oh oh i
was just looking at queens
checkmates here okay right so knight c7
and black has to give up the entire
queen
right right there's no defense against
this i played queen e7
he gives a check and now something we
will also work on the order of things
white to play and win material do you
take the rook first
what do you do first what do you do
second how do you win the game
um i imagine you trade queens first
right
very nice you trade queens and you take
i actually won this freaking game
because i was a little goon
i was a little devil i eventually won
the knight somehow
uh even though it could have evacuated
itself and i won this game but this
taught me a lesson i never forgot this
in conjunction with the lesson
g6 and e6 is one of the worst
combinations of moves you can possibly
play
and the reason that g6 plays a role here
is the bishop is gone from f8
if the bishop was at least on f8 it
would defend this square right
now the square is completely unattended
okay
so i know we took a while on this
particular concept but
i really wanted to hammer this home now
when you play a bunch of games in the
accelerated we are going to see what
your opponents play most commonly
the main move is knight to c3
so continue the development g7 bishop
bishop g7 and the great thing about the
accelerated dragon it's super
freaking natural most people are going
to take on c6 with that knight
which way do you take with i imagine i
take with the b
pawn right you take with the b-pawn
exactly
what um what
do you gain from this it lets me get my
bishop where i want it in the first
place on that
b7 right why do you want it here because
it's going to be attacking king's side
it's going to be attacking these nuts
it's going to be attacking the king so
it's me staring at the pawn
so bishop b7 and then you wanted to move
the pawn out of c6 right
well yeah i just felt like eventually we
went both chilly
what was it called the naraditsky super
[ __ ] or something where you have both
bishops on the same horowitz the
horowitz bishops
the horowitz the horowitz bishops yes so
um i agree that was completely
inadequate reaction
uh bishop b7 is indeed something you
play but i would say that this
the word eventually is problematic here
because look at what could happen
if you put the bishop here you see that
the e4 pawn is super well defended by
white
yeah the problem is even if you play c5
the bishop is going to be biting on
granite here so
i would generally say you want to
develop this bishop along this diagonal
okay just and i want to make a lot of
these observations because i want you to
understand as much as possible
the sort of correct system of developing
your pieces in the accelerated
so let's say that white plays um
bishop bishop e3 bishop uh d3 as as we
did
uh continue developing with with black
what do you do
i'm now developing knight to f6 right um
yes that's perfect okay knight f6 is
great
you're not afraid of this move what
square is now possible for the knight
uh
again the movie five something i told
you at the beginning of the session when
a pawn is pushed like this what squares
are left behind
i don't recall it did what i was looking
at is just centralizing the knight again
but you bring it to d5
exactly right the pawn used to defend
the square sorry not to like over
oh the labor the point and in the
accelerated it's going to be extremely
important to keep this bishop active
so if white tries to defend the pawn
with f4 can we
get the hell rid of this one well also
which are part of our own right yep d6
forcing the trade and we got an amazing
position
so e5 is not dangerous therefore
and you're definitely going to have this
position people usually do this castles
castles
and the great thing about this black's
play is so natural here let's say that
white
develops his other bishop to e3 right
strike in the center black is already
better here
occupy that center and open up your
pieces uh
now i'm just pushing to d5 right here e
takes d5 continue
fake c c pawn what are you threatening
um threatening a fork do you renting a
fork white
actually has a hard time defending it so
let's say white plays bishop to e2
queen defending the pawn how do we
reinforce the threat of the fork while
grabbing more of the center
uh i bring the e pawn to e5 right and go
and now your favorite news ever you
actually can't be in catholicism oh
there it is yeah that's exactly what you
meant actually you meant in this
yeah it was just implied i should have
interpreted that way of course how could
i have thought
it was in another position and black
already is much better
now you will bring your queen and your
rooks in black's got an amazing position
so that's one possible
sequence of events now knight takes c6
at a high level is a mistake
because it allows this pawn here it
allows black to have an easier time
preparing d5 and later
the rope could get to ba so white's best
move here is actually bishop e3
and this one we will talk about later
black goes knight f6
basically black develops in very simple
fashion that's the great thing about the
accelerator and in sicilian in general
the development is supernatural okay
but i think that with openings we'll
definitely ramp it up but i think uh
this is a good place to pause for the
opening segment what do you think
oh you have a lots i'm all over here
yeah um
so in the beginning i already yeah so
this line
we've encountered but i don't okay so
quick review
if bishop c4 and as many questions as
you want i mean i i just don't want to
overwhelm you with too much openings so
when it's the italian that's when i'm e6
blunt the bishop castles one of the keys
do not
rush with d5 d5 you're no rush to play
this move
okay so then we're just doing f6 first
then okay if
e5 uh now we
are just occupying the d5 right
not here although knight t5 is okay now
remember this pawn becomes weak now so
we want to attack it
move the knight i'm doing g4
and now we carve out the development of
our pieces get rid of this pond
okay now we're just doing d6 bingo and
this bishop
the narrative super [ __ ] comes out
too right
i'm going to adopt that if you don't
mind copyright charlie white
but by all means so then
now we're getting the bishop to b7 right
so we just pushed b6
yeah yeah okay exactly b6 this should be
seven and if rookie one here
now we're just taking the pawn on e4
going
and then we're going d5 nice so
this is just one of the possible lines
obviously we have
like i think what we're going to do
openings wise next time is review
c3 we're going to look at the c3
sicilian and we're going to look
more at the main line we're also going
to look at this move bishop b5 it's
called the rosso limo
and here you actually still play g6 so
you play this much like an accelerated
dragon
and um there's actually not as much
theory as people think there is
the sicilian is like mythologized but to
play it at a good
basic level you know it's not like
insurmountable if that makes sense
okay and we're also going to involve the
vm but um
you know openings best like black caviar
are best in small doses
so i propose maybe jump in for one one
two more games then we can maybe draw
some conclusions
let's say you do that yeah but last
question i had in the
as
yes okay and then it was
white going here you took right and then
played knight
uh you the oh in the main line so in the
main open sicilian
white prepares this by going knight f3
and now knight c6 okay i was wondering
when this happened because i know we
took a pawn in one of the examples and i
couldn't remember
so this is the open sicilian yeah my
takes d4 open ceiling because they open
up the position and now you do what
now it's speed and kettling right so i'm
going g6 and then yes
okay and one key uh just point here if
white takes on c6 immediately continue
and then i'm taking on b7 or taking on
b6 with the b7
yeah there's one move i want to alert
you to which is queen to d4 attacking
the rook
stopping bishop g7 but that's not a
problem how can you defend that rock
while developing
i'm just developing knight to f6 okay e5
i'm just going to d5 already your
pattern recognizing this is awesome now
white has this move e6 which
looks intimidating because it exposes
the attack on the rook
and here i'm just going to tell you you
just play f6
and this looks awkward but give this a
chance after e takes d7
you play um you can play bishop take c7
you can even play queen takes d7
uh but but i like bishop takes d7 and
then the move f6 is going to allow you
to prepare what
further central control
the e5 bingo and then you're basically
going to position your bishops like this
you're going to have a super solid
position it takes some getting used to
this is an acquired taste kind of
position
i don't think people are going to do
this in its entirety but i just wanted
you to be aware of this move
this doesn't mean you've done anything
wrong i will analyze this also myself to
make sure i'm telling you exactly the
right moves
so in this position what do they
normally what would they normally do
just develop
so um let me think about this i
i'm going to check actually what well if
i check the
main chest database that's not going to
be representative of what your people do
so knight c3 is the most common move
right
right there is also what do what do
grandmasters play grandmasters play this
move
c4 this is called the marotzi bind
because you bind on the d5 screen named
after jezza marotzi hungarian player
so very important information and this
is what the grand masters played but
this is not what you're going to be
facing and i'll teach you how to play
against this it's a very positional
opening
you're saying i'm not going to attack
i'm going to clamp down on the center
and in the long run i'm going to make it
very hard for black to go d5
right right but your actual play doesn't
change you what do you think black does
it's still just going to probably be
playing normally right
and then we're going down the freaking
main of the main lines and you're
getting all the moves
yeah so then we're just going to be up
there at f6 next yep
natural development wrestling
main line of the marotzi by my friend
just b6 b7 this is interesting that's
one line but d6 is the main line
and this is the beginning of the theory
and we will talk about this position
because that will help you build
understanding
here black has to play in a very
specific manner in order not to get
squeezed
and suffocated but you will not get this
position anytime soon
but you can see that was already nine
freaking moves of theory that you played
instantly
okay and we basically just started so
imagine where we'll be in a freaking
month from now
you'll be the ultimate accelerated
dragon expert
that feels good uh i just need to
remember
oh well yeah we'll review this a million
times and i just want to warn you like
when we do these openings you're going
to forget
first couple you're going to lose some
games you're going to get crushed a
couple times
and you're going to make stupid stupid
mistakes you're going to forget you're
going to mess up the move
on move to and you just have to be
patient with yourself
it's rich telling me to advising someone
to be patient with them themselves
because if i mess up the move or my
entire apartment is usually trashed
but you just have to expect that it's a
rite of passage when you're learning new
openings
okay so hopefully you'll get a chance to
try this like right now
yeah all right so you want to just hop
in the pool and hop in the freaking pool
if you feel like it
yes it's a great way to round off
it's game time baby [ __ ] wait i need to
follow you
oh my god he plays the scene okay so he
plays the c3 sicilian
yeah okay so what you want to do
you want to strike first in the center
you do not want to let him play d4 you
want to strike first
what does that mean so am i just going
to do the marotzi bind with an e5
uh that's possible but not e5 but what's
the other central strike
is it still doing the dragon over here
no d5 the move is deep on to d5
oh i see bingo and after e takes d5
queen takes d5
here's the key normally it's a bad idea
to put the queen on d5 because white
does what move to chase the queen
no i mean if you play the scandi how
does white chase the queen
what does white develop to what square
well it's for a glitch to take me away
from d5 oh he plays c3 with this knight
c3 but here he doesn't have it okay f3
is already very bad
so now and this is one of the keys in
the sicilian oftentimes you don't want
to do anything you just want to keep
developing
i want to see how you develop so am i
going right back to the dragon with the
the knight here at c6 perfect okay thank
you so much ferg lives and i'll thank
everybody properly later i love the
support
okay do i need to be alert here am i
just going right now at g6
yeah okay see that that's the great
thing about this in most cases you can
just play the accelerated moves
they might not be the best moves but
they'll be good enough okay
now you need to be a little bit alert
yeah because now i have that pawn
undefended
yeah so deal with that i can just be
well i can't be six because that hangs
no but
trading is okay okay so i'm just taking
then
that also softens up his d4 pawn and
guess what you're fianchettoing your
bishop so unless he plays this super
accurately
he might end up his center might end up
collapsing here
awesome oh
some uh so i can't take he's now have
okay okay
so i'm just gonna develop absolutely
he should play e5 here that closes up
the center reaches an interesting
position which you need
kind of practice playing okay continue
developing
absolutely
there
when do i look to push b6 to get the
bishop
to uh b7 is that situational it's
situational and here of course the
knight on c6 is going to be hanging so
uh the thing is you don't always have to
develop your pieces
all of them all at once like a piece can
be on its initial square for a time
being
but if you okay so what you want to do
is you want to open you want to soften
up white center so you actually want to
trade
and what you are going to see when you
trade well
what specifically do you treat am i
trading pawns right
yes okay here's the thing do you see
that your queen now
makes contact with the d4 bomb yeah
after he takes with the pawn i think
he's gonna
okay he takes with a knight that's not a
great move because now that bishop on g7
always hearken back to your accelerated
dragon bishop that bishop is a beast
that often comes alive so what do you do
uh well i need to free up the night so i
just trade
and then what can you take
that gives me the pawn now right
absolutely not only the pawn but his
position just collapses now what do you
want to take it with
uh so do i want to do bishop first
you need to keep your sorry that item
needs to be alright you need to keep
your accelerated dragon bishop
okay so i take with knight then yes and
what you're gonna see he's probably
gonna take this
your knight then you take and he can't
even castle
that accelerated dragon bishop is now
preventing his king from castling
so you're upon and you've got a huge
attack go ahead
12 moves you're already basically
winning
all right so the only reason i was doing
bishop first was to have the knight
attacking the bishop yeah i totally
totally understood and
and we'll talk about that but okay so 22
is a good move
now you need to spot his undef he has an
undefended piece right that bishop on b5
yeah so you can bring a piece out and
you can attack that bishop
and you can build a little battery
just push up this f-pawn f6 the other
bishop is what i mean
the bishop on b5 oh i was looking at his
okay i see so that bishop you can attack
with what move
d7 no then
you move your queen oh yeah you're right
because then i blocked the
you blocked the other bishop yeah yeah i
mean queen b6 yeah
okay i see i see gotcha yeah nowhere
you'll you'll
get a better sense of these kinds of
positions very quickly
but does this move make sense you you
get the queen out of the standoff and
you attack the b5 bishop
and it's still protecting the bishop
yeah yeah yep
okay he's good this guy's playing well
okay but now you need to complete your
developments
yeah i was looking at just g sure go
ahead
and that also prevents him castling
along now he can take the pawn on e7 and
if he does
you have a super nice move there you can
sacrifice an exchange
in order to you see that e4 pawn right
pawn is super weak you can get a rook to
e4 at any moment okay so he goes there
now where should you move your rook nice
open file
uh i just want to put it at the a yeah
and what
tactically do you notice immediately
wearing the queen x-raying the queen so
and uh you don't necessarily look for
moves immediately you just notice that
that's enough because depending on what
he does then you might start looking for
discoveries
okay finally he is stumped
and there's gonna be a long time where
you like feel like you're at sea
in these positions but so are your
opponents like nobody below
really 13 1400 studies the sicilian
properly so remember that you're not
going to be
playing people who are at all well
prepared they might have a line chosen
but that's right about it
so and the same goes for your wide
openings by the way okay okay
oh my god you have a beautiful move here
so um
i don't just take the rook with the
[ __ ] not yet
discovery against the queen what comes
to mind
the only check that i saw go ahead do it
but f2 he just takes with the queen but
then keep calculating you have
checkmated one
you see your bishop on g4 you see your
rook on d8
they combine to attack what square oh
i see the d1 yeah and that's where the
puzzles are going to come in yeah
yeah so i'm still just doing this f2
yeah the way i see this is when he plays
rook d1 i notice
which pieces are okay great yeah so
that's just checkmate bringing rook down
congrats on your first sicilian game
yep okay so um
okay so just a couple of things and then
maybe you can play one one last one
um let me invite you
just important because these first
couple of games in the sicilian are
gonna are gonna offer us very important
chances to improve
okay ready
[ __ ] that bad boy one more time
done okay so
c3d5 the rationale behind this makes
sense right
if they take we get away with taking
with the queen and this is the main line
white goes d4 and now keep pressure the
pawn
yes and now i'm just bringing up the
knight to c6 right here
and you almost never want to take the
pawn because what concession does this
make
thinking about what we talked about in
the context of the queen undefined
well now i can just develop the knight
bingo so you want to keep the tension
knight f3 now apply indirect pressure on
this one
when i say indirect pressure what i
basically mean usually is you apply
pressure on the pieces defending a
particular pawn
um but it's also a natural developing
you should see this
regardless of its intention it's just an
intuitive
i'm still feeling ketoing right not yet
first
deal with this bishop where can you put
it
do i go to the g4 yes you seem
mystified at this move yeah cool because
he's just gonna chase it away
okay but wait a minute this bishop is
making contact with the knight what pawn
is this knight defending
oh it's defending the d4 how many
attackers does the d4 pawn have
three so after age three we do what
we take yeah and then even queen takes
you take the queen pawn saves you taken
from the pawn
so even by the way even if he did chase
you away even if he does this
right this cre look at how weak the
knight becomes
knight is now basically undefended it's
pinned so sometimes you want to provoke
that
that's also fine but anyways we'll we'll
talk about that later
f3 knight c6 and you see how adaptable
the accelerated dragon is
you can basically play it against
anything and here
yeah when should i trade pawns in that
situation it was hanging when
is it just when i can't defend it with a
pawn oh you mean this pawn
the move before this we trade we just oh
so yeah it's just because uh you
he wants to take on c5 and uh
also like trading softens up the center
ultimately
the accelerated dragon is a hyper modern
opening
and not to lecture you too much but i
might have talked about this before the
hyper modernists
were a group of people in the 1920s who
developed all of these openings like the
accelerated dragon and king's indian
and these are openings where you allow
your opponent a greater share of the
center
okay which they were laughed out of
every tournament because of that
because like this was anathema you
couldn't say that
the center was all the rage i mean i
know that sounds weird to us now but
literally they were laughed at
but the bottom line in these openings is
you deploy your pieces
uh in sniper like fashion you you attack
white's center from afar
and so you want to do whatever it takes
to soften up white center does it make
sense that this trade
weakens the d4 pawn and it should also
make sense by that same token that the
move d takes e4
applies even more pressure on the pawn
if they had gone f takes e4
what would you do here to the point of
identifying new squares that are now
made
available to your pieces super important
do i just bring the bishop over to g4
first yes
and actually if h3 do you take the
knight
i don't think so just because i asked
him
well uh it's i want to keep the pen
right
um actually no so if you play bishop h5
first of all that's a blunder
you blunder the bishop oh there's no
treat square spread he just pushes up
yeah so when you fiancado you got to be
careful about this but by taking the
knife
look what happens to white center this
d4 pun right it needs to be defended
which means he's got to take with the e
knight which means you have now what
now i have uh just taking the pawn right
bingo
and white's whole position collapses by
the way you should also bear in mind in
such positions
queen a5 checks sometimes this wins a
piece here he can go back to c3 but now
you can do what
this is an even better version of what
we just talked about yeah i just take
the pawn again because
yeah absolutely so so
in that position if we did get the the
bishop to g4
why wouldn't he just take with like a
queen or something well that wouldn't
make any sense everybody i see well then
you take this pawn
yep yeah white can't can't defend both
at the same time
yeah he just loses a pawn regardless
right i mean he he can defend
he can play d5 and he can start but now
it's a runaway train
and now he gives you this square and and
i mean just all of your pieces are
breathing here even if you don't want
the pawn
so that's the point behind dtx4 and i
take c4
you did the same you didn't need to play
bishop g4 you just win the pawn
and now this is what concerned me a
little bit right the move queen v6 i
want this to be automatic how do i find
this move
fundamentally right this bishop is the
only undefended
undeveloped piece so i understand your
instinct to go bishop d7 but there's
just something about it that seems very
passive
not to mention that it drops this bishop
does it actually drop the bishop do you
lose a piece
well i can deliver a check and get the
bishop back do you need to deliver a
check
oh i just take the bishop right away
yeah but is it a good idea to trade
queens even if
you win a bond the answer is no because
this brings white closer to
liquidating right whereas clearly you
are the one attacking
queen b6 building the battery attacking
the bishop
and and everything crumbles get the
bishop out i would even consider getting
the bishop to like e6 you don't always
need to develop the bishop to
quote unquote the most active square
okay you can also play a6 by the way and
chase white special way
so many many possibilities here but now
rook ft8 and this key move bishop f2
you could also have taken on d1
and if queen takes d1 then what do you
do
i just deliver that check with the
bishop right and i want to queen yes and
what about king takes do you want to
find
the most clinical move
be careful here because if you move the
bishop just anywhere he can
block the pin with bishop d3 so you need
to add some more tabasco sauce to that
white queen
uh do i swing it all the way around to
h5
or whoa no no no
um
i just directly attack it at e3 okay
nice bishop e3
oh yeah you saw the arrow sorry i didn't
mean zero but bishop e3 what is the
purpose you attack the queen with two
different pieces
and after bishop takes c3 you don't even
have to take the queen yet
what can you do first i can just take
the bishop first yeah
pins spins spinspins pinspin spins and
this is winning you can also go bishop
c3
but yeah those are the most accurate
pumps
um so does that make perfect sense but
bishop f2
when you start solving problems again
regularly which i want you to do
you're gonna start seeing these moves
pretty quickly uh because i immediately
see a rook appearing on d1 there's my
brain just
inputs that right okay brook can appear
on do you want to check me
because the queen obstructs that's where
but
that's the sicilian frame welcome to the
world
okay so it's just it's going to take
it's going to take a little
bit it's going to take a week two weeks
and i have
infinite patience in that regard and if
you think you're going to get off the
hook
from that drill we once did we're going
to have one lesson where we do that
freaking drill where i give you one
minute basically to win
30 positions where you're up a queen in
a rook to get that speed going as well
what do you say one more for the road
yeah
what was that oh i let off the thing
yeah i'm ready i'll hop in perfect
and fantastic
all right and another blackout
yes as if they couldn't have scripted it
any better aha
oh so this is mainline right mainline
right baby boy stuff
absolutely you're going 1960 better okay
let's see if he goes yeah so then
this is where i take take take that
and fiance welcome to the accelerated
dragon my friend
scripted okay main line we talked about
this bishop
three or nine seas we talked about
knight c6 i said that that's the most
okay bishop e3 is the main line
develop and then it is uh
yeah you are playing
big boy opening theory right now
he's probably gonna okay f4
so it's still a castle so i would say
here
you have to ask yourself what is the
purpose of f4 what move does it prepare
e5 yeah so can we there is a move you
you want to make here which you want to
make anyway
in these positions to stop e5 yeah play
d6 first
so be flexible in your development i'm
teaching you an opening scheme
but what has to transcend that is
first and foremost you have to look at
what your opponent is doing because your
opponents are going to do a wide variety
of
various things and sometimes you're
going to have to modify or change the
order of things a little bit
okay so in this position if he pushes e5
still do i want to take or do i just
want to go d5 right away
well if he pushes e5 you can't go knight
d5 that hangs you can also go knight g4
by the way that look at that g4 square
that can uh set his entire position
in disarray because his bishop defends
the knight on d4
and and his position may collapse okay
so this should be five you you have to
attend to that
uh defend the pin you know how to defend
against these pins
yeah um at one point in time i'm sure
right again do i just bring the bishop
there at d7 yes bingo
and one area where i you've grown and i
like it is
you don't always now try to develop
develop a piece of the quote-unquote
most active square like bishop on d7
a lot of people look at it and say
that's a shitty bishop not really it's
fine it's doing its job
and you actually already have a super
nice move here
i already mentioned this move too before
yeah uh is it g4 nice knight g4
very cool if he moves his bishop guess
what wins the game is the fianchetto and
bishop on g7 he's got to take on c6
which is a concession we talked about
yeah he's already in trouble
now you could have all you could have
also castled but that's
a good idea that's a good thing a good
lesson of not eliminating
not being on autopilot eliminating the
autopilot
always considering the concrete
resources in a given position rather
than sort of
making the next move on the laundry list
so does this move knight g4 makes sense
yeah
and he played f4 on move seven that was
a mistake
because that left the bishop on e3
undefended you're exploiting that it
makes perfect logical sense
and ultimately okay perfect
you're winning how in many ways actually
yeah so i just take that bishop yes and
then
from there it's he's probably gonna take
back and lose this queen but
he should take on c6 but you're gonna
end up a piece off anyway
if he takes uh i'm having a hard time
figuring out the next line if he takes
on uh e3 with the queen okay
the next move is oh it's taking the
knight on with
with the bishop with the bishop pinning
his queen winning his queen
and the accelerated dragon bishop wins
the game there he can
cut his losses okay he does now here you
have to be very precise
what you want to do here look at okay
what do you think black should do
um why would you take i was looking at
the taking the rook
that's fine that's one of the
possibilities probably not the exact
most precise move but it's fine
because yeah do it and you'll see what
would happen if you react correctly and
then we'll
well this is winning this is also
reading
basically the reason is that that knight
on f1 is going to be trapped
and you could have won a piece instead
of an exchange which is marginally
better
okay so i just take here with the queen
of course
well he doesn't take on f1 he if he's
five head he's gonna move his knight
from d4
let's say to f3 or b3 and he will i mean
i think he'll see that
and then okay so he does something
similar which is also
fine now this is a very good
chance for me to remind you of a
principle when you have a piece that is
lost
okay remember that you want to give this
piece up for as much you want to take
with you as
much as you can if you're already losing
the peace you might as well freaking
give it up for something so what do i
mean here
just taking the pawn on h2 bingo and
when you blunder pieces and you will
um that's a good way to cut your losses
okay so now you're up and exchanging
upon
continue development i just want a
capsule yeah absolutely
absolutely now think about
you know are there pieces that could be
deployed into the game that are
currently not doing anything
uh what i was looking at is pushing the
f7 pawn to f5 to try and open this up
here to get the
reaction that's not a bad idea at all
but remember f5e takes f5 you cannot
take with the on f5 with the rook you
can take with the pawn though
yeah now i'll tell you that in this okay
he goes that fight himself
i'll tell you this in the sicilian the
rook
on a8 generally belongs on c8 that is
just a
rule of the sicilian the reason why is
the c file you can see that it would
pressure the knight on c3 the c file is
what's called a semi-open file
there's only pawns of one color on that
file
and so because there's a white pawn on
c2 this benefits black
so you can go ahead and do that okay uh
no
so just write to c8 then kc8 now do you
see that the move f5 doesn't actually
create any threats
that's a paper tiger it may look
intimidating but there's
it doesn't do anything at all in fact it
weakens the square it gives you a nice
little outpost on what square
potentially
with check two on e5 beautiful little
square
now you don't need to rush with that
check but just keep that in mind
now the rook on on c8 is not even done
yet where could it go from here to twist
the knife
uh are we looking at c5 and getting it
over to h5
potentially if he takes the pawn then
yes but if he doesn't if he leaves the
pawn on f5 where can the rook go
oh am i just going to c4 though bingo
i'm telling you have a freaking sense
for these positions i just knew it
and i can see it rook c4 attacks the
knight
and uh he has to move the knight and his
position collapses
yeah this guy knew okay so i'm just
playing that now yeah
there's many ideas of this movie you can
also stack the rooks on c8 okay
he's playing this pretty well but now
you can strike in the center
see this is a good time he's moved his
pieces away so you can rip apart the
center
yeah so now i do i do i just play d5
here yeah
sorry excited yes i'm excited for you to
be playing this opening this is going to
pay off
in a big way okay b3
i have to drop the rook now yeah that's
okay do i drop it all the way back or do
i want to drop like c5
back all the way c5 would run under the
cross hairs of the queen on f2
it would be a discovery there and this
is one of the other things i want you to
pay attention to increasingly is
you put a piece on a square a lot of
people are averse to bringing a piece
back to where it came
well i just came from there but the
situation changes and that's
generally not a reason to do to not do
that okay now what
complete the job i just take now yeah
exposing the attack on the night
nice nice nice
yeah he's busted he's got 20 seconds
this is your first day playing sorry i
did
okay what can you tell me about the rook
on d1
undefended bingo so do you have to worry
about the x-ray the queen is actually
in charge here can you attack that
knight uh
if i take what bishop he takes i can't i
can't can i
you can nope but you can apply pressure
on it with with a piece that is
currently on
not doing anything i'm looking at e5
with a piece that's currently e5 you
cannot pass on you
oh right right i've totally forgot about
there is a piece that's not doing
anything it's sitting on f8
you should see this oh okay so it just
moves
don't lose on time ramping up i'm gonna
have a big problem
a very [ __ ] problem we lose this game
on time
collect the harvest i just take the pawn
yeah
white upon the knight okay the plot is
fine this is fine it was fine now you
take the rook and you win the rook
but um and he takes on e7 you can talk
okay just take back
and find you got to move fast tuck the
king away on h8
okay bring queen back to d4 now or
something
wait queen d4 movement between g7
you can take the knight take the knight
and pre-move everything jesus premove
every move has to be a premium of
charlie literally look one square
forward pre-move everything
this is good practice pre-moving move
bingo that's the new freaking charlie
that's what i'm talking about
you would have lost that game on time
you can pre-move with the best of them
so when you reach 3-4 seconds
and you are probably going to have a
time scramble in pog champs
there has to be a threshold you reach
four seconds you pre-move whatever it
takes
it doesn't matter what move you make i
can't emphasize that enough
okay and you did that here very
successfully
okay so my i had a quick question though
please
so let me invite you to a board yeah and
we will practice the speed as well by
the way
okay yeah at the end when i took pawn
instead of the knight
i was wondering why knight was the
better call
right so maybe i'm just not remembering
the position right in my head
yeah so basically here rook fda attacks
the knight
the knight can he defend with c3 first
of all
uh no because he hangs the pawn right
that's why we put the rook there
now taking the pawn i suppose is fine
but taking the knight is just a free
knight
i mean why why take the pawn and
slightly weaken your king i guess it's
fine
because he has to move this night and
then you can take the knight i guess
it's fine but but this is more pure
okay this is more pure and then you can
take the pawn with the queen
without ruining your king's side okay
that makes sense
but this move rook da right now e5 he
had on passant does that make sense can
you make that umpisan on the board
and believe it or not this is actually
good for black because now he's gotta
move his queen
and you can again make the move e5
and this i mean this is a funny
technique and this time he doesn't have
one
exactly that's what the knight is saying
so that would have also
been fine but rook d8 is again the
cleanest
um in terms of other notes this move
knight g4 is what i want you to keep in
mind whenever they play f4
that bishop on e3 loses its protection
and um and it's a matter of time until
you play an ig4 he should have probably
gone h3
to stop it oh i remember the other thing
uh when i told you
and then took rook what was the better
oh so it was actually
just to take on d4 which does
many things it you win a piece
okay now you have a discovered check
against the king on the cards
and you're still attacking the rook so
mathematically speaking you get the same
thing you get in the game
except you also win the knight for
example if he moves his rook to e1
give me the best discover check here oh
just going to
see bingo and you win the rook and
you're up a full rook
there and somewhere once okay
so it's a simple matter in these
situations of not stopping the
calculation because
you kind of stopped and said ah he takes
on f1 and then i take the knight
not to put words in your mouth i feel
like that's what might have happened but
the knight what i see
the knight is not getting out he could
have well he basically did that he
couldn't move the knight away now you
have to give away
tonight you're only up in exchange which
is still great but not
the same as a rook that makes sense
so but overall i cannot be happier with
how the sicilian is starting out
and this is just the beginning so on
deck for us next we're going to
tighten the screws here in some of these
lines
and we're going to get started on the
vienna and you're going to have a ton of
fun in that line as well
okay cool once again what you want to
hit in the meantime
is um you want to do puzzles you know as
much as you can you want to play
and if you play on your own i will go
through your games and assemble
i'll try to assemble uh puzzle sets on
the basis of your mistakes so that'll
give me a lot of material
to incorporate and cycle into future
lessons where we'll talk about your
mistakes
so you know i won't police that too much
play as much as your heart desires
[Music]
you